the agenda is set i'm brent goff in
berlin it's time to talk
world leaders taking their time on syria
is it already too late to act
lights camera politics the german
chancellor tv debate did it make a
difference for the voters
and germany confronting its nazi past in
france how ghosts continue to haunt
all right welcome to the show everyone i
have invited three people today to talk
argue and pry apart these headlines my
first guest today is henrietta heimbach
she is a franco german relations analyst
at the german council on foreign
relations henrietta good to have you on
the show today my second guest is a
political campaign advisor here in
germany he earned his stripes in the u.s
by working on barack obama's campaigns
in 2008 and 2012. i'm happy to welcome
back to the show julius fandelar julius
good to see you again and
my next guest has spent the last two
years helping to smuggle cash from
germany to the rebels in syria he is
co-founder of adopt a revolution which
is based right here in berlin i'm happy
to welcome to the show elias perabo
elias good to have you on the show let
me open up and just let's start with
syria if the arguments for a military
intervention in syria are so compelling
why all of this feat dragging
well first of all any strike against
syria
without any resolution from the security
council are going to be a violation in a
serious violation of international law
so we have to be really careful on that
of like doing a strike against the
sovereignty of syria second of all
um for the people on the ground it's not
going to help them if we do a strike
without a concept of the day after the
strike all right but we know we're not
going to get that u.n um security
council action right julius i mean that
we're not going to get that u.n unity
well i think it's unlikely at this point
uh i think most importantly is public
opinion at this point people looking to
the u.s to take leadership and if you
look at the polls 50 of americans are
saying they're not ready for u.s
military involvement in syria so i think
the president is working right now with
congressional approval in order to shore
public support get the public behind and
then be able to strike in syria all
right but the the judge you know the
verdict is still out on washington and
henrietta it looks like mr hollande in
france they're actually the only
force right now willing to shoot some
rockets at syria um actually it looks
like but i think they they won't do it
alone so they wait um for the decision
the congress will take um soon so then
we see tomorrow there will be a debate
in the um french senate so but without
any vote so we see how it goes but he
won't definitely do it alone yeah
exactly no one wants to do anything
alone and no one wants to do anything at
all right now let's let's get a status
check on syria washington as we heard is
waiting for congress to give its
blessing next week at the earliest the
french as henrietta said our debating
intervention this week britain is out
altogether the u.n security council you
can forget that the arab league a lot of
talk no action and syria's president
bashar al-assad he feels so emboldened
that he has warned the world attack me
and you'll pull the trigger on a middle
east armageddon
the world has been wrestling with
intervention in syria since the conflict
began but on august 21 it appeared
assad's forces had crossed a red line
images of an alleged poison gas attack
near damascus sent shockwaves around the
world and international response looked
imminent
british prime minister david cameron led
the early push for punitive action but
the use of military force was
unexpectedly voted down in parliament
the united states upped the rhetoric but
president barack obama's call for
military action eventually came with a
caveat
he wants a green light from the u.s
congress the united states should take
military some analysts say military
strikes could make things even worse for
syrians
for now the world is waiting but with
the death toll mounting how long can it
afford to
elias
tell me what the people in syria that
you're in contact with what are they
telling you are they telling you that a
chemical weapons attack happened yes
they do and how do they say committed
that
well most of them said it's going to be
the government but honestly even they
told us that is that most of them are
not sure about it because how could they
tell they just saw especially our
partners who were very close they saw
rockets fired them um in that area they
don't know really where these workers
were coming from but there's a lot of
evidence which shows that it
probably is going to come from how can
there be any doubt um do this julius
henry both you guys can chime in on this
how can there be any doubt i mean assad
and his regime they have the means to
deploy chemical weapons i mean we're
living in a fairy tale if we think the
rebels are equipped to deliver chemical
weapons aren't we
henry what do you say
well i think it's not that clear so as
you explained even people on the ground
can't really say
it wasn't like that so i would say
it's so important for international
decisions um to have these evidence that
they try to um collect right now so it's
i think that would be important for
foreign response and why especially
after iraq so julius why is it so hard
for the world to believe the chemical
weapons story i mean go back to iraq
remember uh the presentation from the
security council and the evidence that
was supported uh presented
with regard to weapons of mass
destruction and then having to go back
on that so i think the ramifications
could be severe if in fact you know
based on attack on on wrong evidence at
the same point public opinion is just
against any sort of involvement i
mentioned 50 in the u.s
populations against any sort of
involvement the same goes for germany
and we just had the vote in uh in in
parliament in the uk so uh the public is
against it you have to be very careful
in order to not make any mistakes and
not shore up any support against you
elias are you for or against a military
attack well
why don't we start what the people are
for in syria and what our partner said
first because i think it's very good to
hear the voice of from syria directly
and when we ask our partners it was
quite surprising that most of our
partners who have been for very long
against any interventions say at this
point yes something has to be done and
we are very much in favor for this
intervention however they link it to
conditions they say first of all
any intervention has to only target
military targets in syria second of all
the intervention has lead to it cannot
be the whole conflict cannot be resolved
militarily so any intervention has to
lead to um debates has to lead to
diplomatic efforts in the end and what
they said third is
despite all the debate of intervention
and what they really need on the ground
is humanitarian aid as well as aid for
the silver project and this has to be
done like really immediately so the
people you're helping in syria they say
yes to the attacks but they don't want
the attacks to knock bashar al-assad out
of power they say they can't this this
is the thing i mean bashar al-assad
really has a lot of places to hide he
still has quite a lot of people inside
syria who are supporting him um it's
going to be very hard against the syrian
military to really do a strike which is
going to like defend them in the end but
what's the purpose of a strike then
either you go in you wipe out the
perpetrator or you stay out
no their idea is to weak the military
it's too great
exactly and then you have the free
syrian army who should like step in and
sort of do the rest and the second issue
is to bring it back on the diplomatic
agenda and to bring syria back into the
debate where there's sort of nothing has
happened during the last like two months
is there confidence
among the people that you're helping
that the the free syrian army that the
the opposition that they will come
together and provide a a better
alternative to assad
yes there is i mean a lot of people see
they've got a lot of bad pr in the last
two years very much too and a lot of
people say that's also the reason why
the military is like support at the
moment they say what we are facing is
that you have the free syrian army on
the one side and then there's more and
more global geologists coming into syria
and fighting their own fight so what
they are saying is if the regime say
stay strong all the gear is going to
stay strong because there's a
correlation between those two
and what they say okay if the regime is
going to be weakened we're going to take
care of the islamists we're going to
take care about the jihadists do you
trust them
well so far a lot of syrians have proven
that they have done
in the opposition fact they have done
quite a lot of stuff and even on the
aegean stuff you can see the towns where
uh they're run by the jihad yesterday a
lot of the civil population are against
them they're protesting against them
they also fighting against them there's
a lot of fighting between the free
syrian army and
see this is why this is what i think it
confuses a lot of people i mean you've
even wrote that you think a solution to
this problem in syria will only come
once iran is pulled to the negotiating
table how can you believe that the
jihadists and these extremists that they
will be fought in syria if you've got
the iranians sitting at the table
helping you know co-direct the peace
plan well i think we have to to look at
two fronts right the one is to weaken
assad and to weaken assad we do have to
talk to iran we have to talk to russia
and we do have to stop the supply of
arms to the syrian regime
on the other side germany and the other
western state should immediately talk to
turkey because most of these global
gld's are going coming through turkey to
the northern part of syria and really
harming the revolution so what turkey
has to do is to close their border for
these uh
jihadists who are going to syria and
turkey's going to tell you that they're
doing that anyway but i mean look at the
numbers coming out this week two million
refugees now out leaving the country a
lot of them going to turkey julius is
there any type of international
concerted effort that is realistic right
now i think it's a bad situation and
they're no good option on the table so
you know what is the president going to
do is he going to strike unilaterally he
has to wait for congress in order to get
approval in order to make sure that he
has the political backing in the united
states germany right now is not willing
to act due to the elections i think
merkel will be falsely advised to sort
of make any move right now we're waiting
for britain and france and so i don't
think there's any any good option that
anyone could be taking is this still
america's game though i think it is
right now i think we're waiting for what
happens in congress and whether the
president is going to decide to take
action or not
is it going to be henrietta in the end
an american french
alliance that's going to go in and take
out or at least degrade assad's
capabilities
it really depends on the um vote in
congress and what will happen in france
but iran's not going to allow the the
assembly in in paris to decide whether
or not he orders a strike right
he's not going to play an obama right
now no it doesn't look like but um he
could well tomorrow there will will be
the debate and no vote but um we'll see
how it goes and but i think the french
president will go for a vote if he's
sure that they at the um
on the assembly will vote for it so yeah
i mean where is i'm going to ask all
three of you where is your anger about
what has happened here i mean whoever
committed this chemical weapons attack
it was still a breach of a convention
that's almost 100 years old not to use
chemical weapons doesn't that in itself
warrant the international community the
u.n included going in and striking at
assad alias you know what anger means
mainly even the last two years right the
international diplomatic efforts on
syria but let's stay on the chemical
weapons though for a second i mean isn't
that a reason in itself to strike at
assad well if there's not evidence on
the table um yes something has to be
done but it's not that easy that's
that's the whole question but i don't
know
inspectors do you trust the u.n
inspectors they have said sarin gas was
found exactly but they haven't said
who have done it right this is the whole
issue on it and the other part is even
if you like even if you go forward
emotionally and say okay we have to do
something we have to like bomb
syria on this table the question is
what's going to happen after it and this
is also the experience from iraq it's
not going to help the people on the
ground if you strike assad hard and then
he's going to take a revenge again on
his own people it's not going to help
the people in syria are you people
afraid of that are they afraid of
revenge from assad yes a lot of them say
okay if they only come in and punish
assad and like leave immediately and
we're going to be like in the same mess
as before which is going to be even
worse and then assad is going to punish
us he's not going to punish the
americans he's going to punish his own
people all right what's it going to take
for you to be convinced that chemical
weapons were used by assad
evidence on the ground i think what we
need is sort of an investigation by the
un
um who go in and figure out who has done
it but that's that's probably not going
to happen julius and then the ghost of
iraq is haunting us again isn't it it's
right there at the doorstep and so i
think the question becomes what do you
do right now do you send airstrikes uh
are you gonna launch some some rockets
uh christmas sauce uh you know sort of
what you're hearing on the ground is
that from military experts is that you
know
any sort of military attack is not
necessarily going to take out all the
chemical weapons so that's not certainly
a good option the second portion what
you just mentioned is you know look at
the ramifications if you go in with
airstrikes uh
talking about up to two million refugee
refugees that are going to be on the
move so you know the humanitarian
consequence is going to be severe and
again there's no end game in sight what
are you going to do
what about this use of chemical weapons
i mean isn't it up to the us again or
maybe the us and france to be the
world's policeman and to say a breach of
this convention will not be tolerated
period
isn't the us is the only you know player
in town
i think it's more complex than that
yes the u.s is the only player in town
but at the same time france is ready to
gear up
germany has sort of indicated that it
will probably play some sort of role
even though the chancellor is very
careful in stating what exactly that
role is going to take but
i think there is going to be some sort
of intervention the question is just is
it going to be airstrikes is it going to
be cruise missiles uh i would imagine
that boots on the grounds are very
unlikely at this point
unlikely yep
and what about this notion i mean aren't
you shocked
that the french were once seen in
america as these cheese-eating surrender
monkeys and now everyone's saying well
the french are on our side
well maybe there's a change in politics
especially when you look at
iraq at the french politics towards the
iraq war but what i want to say that
actually it really shocks me and makes
me angry that um that there was this use
of chemical weapons but it's actually a
violation of international war so it has
to be also an international response it
can't be a unilateral um response by the
us or by france so but russia and china
are going to block any attention yeah so
you have to you have to um find a
solution for that and there will be
evidence so yeah but where where is the
where's the anger coming from where's
the german government at this point
saying hey russia and china you guys are
dropping the ball on
enforcing this international convention
on chemical weapons
well i think they try it in a diplomatic
way that's what they do right now right
now so france is speaking to russia and
to putin so but nothing's going to
happen julius now because we've got this
election coming up here in germany we've
got the g20 coming up and there's been
talks that you know merkel is going to
sit down with uh putin and we know the
relationship between obama and putin is
certainly strained so yeah maybe
something will come from that but i
think it's unlikely at this point um
alias um you have said many times that
you and your organization adopt a
revolution you guys tried to keep as
much of your activity secret as possible
do you feel like even today you're being
watched and followed by assad secret
police here in berlin
well i'm pretty sure they'll watch us
because they're pretty good in what they
do in their secret service so i'm quite
sure they'll watch us but let me just
get one point more about this
last debate i think
we are very i mean everybody agrees that
something has to be done in fact this is
really terrible and horrible crime which
has been done in syria um however i
think that the clue is not only to focus
militarily you could also say if the
americans want to do something why don't
they sit down with the iranians and talk
about syria this would be like a
realistic option what they could do and
i mean why don't they even look into
that and this is what i think is quite a
problem which is like beyond sort of the
military strike that would be though and
that would be a huge move for obama to
agree to that wouldn't it julius i mean
can you imagine that happening this year
comes out and says any sort of strike on
syria is going to have ramifications
with regard to israel's safety i think
it's very difficult for the president or
the white house to sit down right now
and talk with uh with iran about any
sort of you know diplomatic resolutions
in that respect so
i think you know public opinion is going
to play a huge difference in this and i
mentioned it before the vast majority of
american serbians said the president's
doing everything to shore public support
right now and i think as much as you
know atrocities have been committed i
think the president is very well aware
of that but i think you know the
international communities play a strong
role i think the president is looking at
chancellor merkel uh to make a
commitment to get engaged uh and at the
same time it's going to be a question of
how does the public react in the united
states yeah public opinion that's sort
of the dilemma right because when we
talk about the military strike but
against the country you're talking about
sort of a
serious violation of international law
doing their strike on the one side and
we say okay even in america the public
opinion is against the strike on the
other side we're talking about
diplomatic talks to iran so i know it's
a big step for america but also in spite
of what's on the table i think it's
quite necessary it's hard though for
people to imagine talking with iran
because iran is also a system that if
they had complete control over syria
they would not allow the civil society
groups uh that you're supporting with
your money so iran is still like
deploying weapons to syria so i mean
you're asking the us to basically
negotiate with what you would say is the
devil yes i think this is sort of what
it has to be done because as far as i
mean
if it continues that iran is going to
deploy weapons to the regime even if the
military strikes and we don't gonna
we're not gonna have boots on the ground
so even if they're gonna strike with
missiles or from the airplanes um we're
still gonna have the flow of weapon into
syria and this is just gonna be a huge
problem all right let's move on let's
bring it um into germany for a second we
know that intervention in syria is a no
go for this country germany now
confirmation came again this week during
the only tv debate between the two
candidates who would like to lead the
country after the national election
later this month now the tv debate it
was a talker on twitter i watched it i
tweeted what i was seeing the tweets
that got the most traction were the ones
about the color of german chancellor
angela merkel's necklace
well today we asked did the tv debate
make a difference or was it just another
campaign
accessory
with three weeks to election day in
germany this was billed as the main
event
a showdown between chancellor angela
merkel and her main challenger pierre
steinbrueck of the social democrats
for steinbrook it was a major chance to
close the gap in the opinion polls
for merkel it was 90 minutes to convince
voters to keep the status quo
both sides came out claiming victory but
the post-debate analysis was
inconclusive showing neither delivered a
knockout blow but the face-off did draw
a huge audience more than 17 million
watched on tv and hashtag tv duel
briefly topped the trending charts on
twitter
although the buzz was mainly about
angela merkel's german flag colored
necklace
the election's one and only tv debate is
over but will it make a difference come
september 22nd
yeah i mean that's the big question is
angelus is it going to make a difference
when people go to the polls on the 22nd
i think always makes a difference when
people go to the polls it's an electoral
process and now a democratic process of
people should turn out especially if you
look at the numbers from 2009 when we
had the lowest turnout in voter history
in german history all right but that's a
nice pc comfortable answer julius it's
true is it going to is it going to
influence the vote on the 22nd the tv
debate yeah i don't think it is i think
why not in order for a tv debate to make
any sort of difference in uh in a
political campaign is you know it has to
be first of all it has to be competitive
race and right now the race is not that
competitive second of all there has to
be a clear winner that emerges from a
debate and i don't think either
candidate emerged as a clear winner and
third of all you have to dominate the
week after the second week after and
right now the news headlines that we're
seeing coming out this week is nobody
won clearly so no clear winner no
decision no clear winner no decision did
everybody here watch the debate i'm sure
everyone did
i'm going to say one word and to
describe and you tell me if i'm right or
wrong boring
alias yes very much it was not really a
debate though it was more uh both
candidates were talking to their
audience not with each other and this
was very boring in the end do you agree
henrietta i would agree but it's like um
because it's about politics so it's not
it's it's not just entertainment so um
i think there was no there was there was
no education no entertainment right but
um i think it has to be something in
between it was boring it could have been
moral um
literally but
i think it's an exchange of arguments
and it's important for um people also to
see that the person that they vote are
like act responsible that they can
explain their arguments in a in a
objective way as well
julius explain to our international
viewers why is this campaign the tv
debate included why is it such a
sleeping pill right it's it's a drag
right there's no excitement and i think
one of the reasons is that the
chancellor's just so far ahead in the
debates second of all there doesn't seem
to be a clear alternative the
distinctions between the spd and the cdu
the conservative party aren't that great
so there's no narrative there's no sort
of changed movement there's no feeling
that people are
not satisfied with the status quo and i
think that's a big problem the great
challenge for the sbd the social
democratic party to sort of get any sort
of momentum going on are there no issues
that could differentiate the candidates
there's certainly issues but when you
look at europe and the year crisis is
that the number one issue the argument
merkel is going to be making is that you
know i've navigated germany through the
crisis pretty well look at everyone
around us look at greece look at italy
look at spain they're not doing nearly
as well as we are we're doing pretty
well we have continuous growth
and the economy is strong so there's one
argument that's completely taken off the
table and any sort of attempt that the
opposition is making is going to be
knocked down by the chancellor by you
know sheer economic numbers what about
syria we talked about that before you
know before the show syria only came up
in the debate in the last 10 minutes of
the show
alias couldn't syria be
a an election winner
for
the you know for steinbrook or is it
also just a can an issue that no one
cares about
i don't think it's going to be an
election winner however i mean both were
very weak on this topic both sort of
just said they're not going to go in
militarily they did not say what
alternative they would like offer they
did not say anything about refugees they
did not say anything about like
humanitarian or development aid going
through syria and i think this is really
an opportunity most both of them really
missed well i think i have to disagree i
think it was smart politics the polls
show 50 58 of german voters are against
any sort of german involvement so any
candidate coming out and saying we're
going to be more aggressive we're going
to uh you know get involved militarily i
think as a huge mistake politically and
i think that would cost votes um it's
not that sort of uh you know situation
where schroder came out clearly stating
that there's not going to be any german
involvement in iraq
i don't think the same
moment and i don't think either one
candidate are the candidates are the
candidates lying to the voters about
syria i would disagree though because i
mean people are shocked in germany as
well about the pictures we're getting
from syria about the chemical attacks
right and
it's true that you don't go in
militarily but if you would say okay due
to these pictures we send in a lot of
humanitarian aid we've sent out our like
mediship from the bundesliga or
something else we develop that's what we
are our strengths is in germany we send
humanitarian head that would be a good
call and people would agree on it
because they have these pictures in
their minds and all of a lot of people
out there thinks something has to be
done even if it's not military right but
that's what both candidates mentioned
during the debate that there's going to
be a support but there's not going to be
any sort of charming lead
why didn't i i asked this thing about
about being lied to because
steinbrook couldn't he have looked at
angela merkel in the face and said you
say today we will not help with any
military intervention but after the
election you're going to be first in
line to help any type of international
force well i think it's a difficult
situation let's assume he gets elected i
think the situation on the ground in
syria can change pretty quickly and
public opinion can change pretty quickly
so i think you can't be too too much on
the offense here because you have to
might have to roll back steinberg pretty
much
said you know he's not going to be
there's not going to be any involvement
but at the same time i think he's been
around long enough to know that things
can change but i think syria and foreign
policy is not the main issue i think
it's domestic issues that matter the
most and i think that was the main topic
of this debate people looking at job
numbers people looking employment people
looking at you know the rents in our
pension system and those are some of the
more important topics but again i don't
think either candidate was able to sort
of win the debate over for himself and
if i can just make one one last point
going into election day in less than
three weeks uh one third of the german
electorate is still undecided they don't
know who they're going to be voting for
and i think that's that's the critical
mass that you can reach here and debate
so you've got a third um
they're still on the fence henrietta
what about this idea that the germans
just have it too good right now low
unemployment
most people have a job
um the health care system works for the
most part i mean the germans are you
know they're sitting pretty
well i think there might be one reason
like crisis always show that um like the
the parties at the at the at the edge
get more votes so there could be a
reason also economy and europe is
getting better and better so i think
it's the point for for merkel as well
even when the spd has done a lot before
that as well but um
i think it's a point for for merkel so
it's a very good time for her to have
elections right now
and regarding european politics for
example there's not much difference
between
the spd and social democrats and social
democrats and the um conservatives so
what about these the this this third of
the electorate right now how are how are
the parties going to get these people
google
wants to introduce all of the candidates
online
and in order to have access to this
though google gets access to your
personal data that's a huge reservoir
you know what i'm talking about that's
how obama won i mean he had access to
the voting patterns and the likes and
dislikes of the voters is that where
germany is headed to get inside the the
heads of these undecided voters using
the internet first of all i'd like to
reject the premise of the question
because i don't think barack obama won
because any sort of online campaign i
think he won because he had the stronger
narrative because he had the strong
message
but you wouldn't argue with me and
saying that he used the internet the
strengths of knowing what people like
and dislike absolutely and i think he
did a fantastic job mobilizing his
supporters now is that happening here i
don't think it is happening to nearly
the same extent i think there's
tremendous potential there now can you
go out and convince anyone to vote just
by sort of tweeting at them or posting
some pretty facebook pictures absolutely
not especially undecided voters and a
third of germans are still undecided
they're never going to be convinced by
any sort of notion that you know they're
going to be tweeted at or see some sort
of election fee to over
on google
people are only going to be convinced in
a personal conversation if you and i sit
together down together and we talk about
personal issues talk about the issues
that matter most to you and i think
that's the greatest challenge for all
parties uh to when they try to reach
undecideds go out have personal
conversations activate your base
make sure people talk to their neighbors
i think this is where the main
difference can be made in these last
couple of weeks in order to reach these
undecideds i mean you sound like a good
electioneering man there julius do you
guys agree with him ellie's do you agree
i think so i'm not so much into like
social media
so i also think that the narrative is
sort of the front thing which has to go
forward but how can you say you're not
into social media when on the night of
the tv debate
um the event the tv debate was the most
tweeted event in the world for a few
minutes that's huge that's tremendous
potential there are you telling me that
the the christian democrats and the the
social democrats are just going to yawn
and and ignore that no it's huge but it
stayed i mean the debate stayed boring
right it did not change the topic of the
debate and still people went out and
said okay we undecided because there was
no debate at least on the table and this
hasn't changed because social media was
around well i think you know if i might
charm in there yeah what facebook
twitter all these social networks are
tremendously effective for it sort of
getting your own base rallied right
steinrich has some momentum in this
debate and the chancellor made some good
points in the debate and if the cdu and
the sbd the parties can sort of harness
that momentum via the online channels
get people involved in the campaign and
have them go out after that talk to
their friends and their families i think
this is where the momentum comes and
where it sort of converts into actual
votes but just hoping that because
someone retweeted you he's going to turn
out and vote for your party i think
that'd be pretty naive i mean have any
of you been contacted by any politicians
via social media
nope no
no i mean have you seen any type of
campaigning on social media
no i think everyone has a twitter
account right like i mean
a lot of people do um but from the
politicians so like
i wouldn't say like social media things
concerns only like the young people a
lot of um we have a lot of elderly
people in germany so i think that's why
it's not that like
it's massive but it doesn't contain
everyone of the population so okay and
we also have all these posters here in
germany and and talk to me julius about
these posters i see this and i feel like
it's 1955 all over again right i mean
post is that sort of tradition in
germany right elections couple weeks
left every party puts up posters
tremendous chunk of the budget they look
the same they pretty much all look the
same and you can't really differentiate
them one is yellow the other one is blue
the other one's green but that's
probably the only distinction now you
know historically a tremendous budget of
the uh portion of the campaign budget is
invested in uh in posters 60 60 huge i
can't believe at the same time there's
no credible research that shows that
posters have any sort of impact in the
us we used to say yard science or the
equivalent to posters yard signs don't
vote and i think that's true uh people
have to be talked to no poster with any
sort of generic slogan is going to make
a difference in getting you either
persuade you from voting from one party
to that makes you aware that there's
election actually that is true that is
true but let me ask all of you before we
move on would you be in favor of getting
rid of the posters all together and
using something else henrietta what
would you be in favor of getting rid of
them
well i think um well actually i don't
care so i think it's it's most important
is that people um get information about
the positions of the parties that
they're aware of that there's election
that they will go there so i think if
posters are a way to to help with that
it's a good idea okay
i think seriously i think postals are
quite important to tell people that the
election is coming up so that's 60 of
the budget exactly that's the problem i
think also
a lot of these posters can be like left
out and this money should be spread
somewhere if we go to sleep on the
evening of september 22nd and wake up on
september 23rd will we have missed
anything
julius
as long as we've voted beforehand we've
probably done everything we could have
done but at the same time i think this
election is important people should go
out and make sure their voices are hurt
and uh but will we have missed anything
julius probably not probably not that's
what henry what do you think well you
never know what will change so i'm not
sure if the results right now is will be
the same so
can be everything can be um a big
coalition okay all right alice what do
you think will it be a sleeper or will
we see something important i think it's
going to be a sleeper a sleeper all
right there we go that's what i wanted
to hear all right let's move on now
germany as we all know
there's the camera is considered a role
model around the world for confronting
the ghosts of its past this week for the
first time ever a german president will
visit the french village of oradour now
that's the site of a nazi-led atrocity
germans aren't talking much about the
visit instead a viral satirical video
about killing a young adolf hitler is
getting much more play and much more
chatter and it begs the question what is
the best way to remember an ugly history
is being irreverent the modern way of
showing respect
this is the french village of oradour
suglan
joachim gauck will be the first german
president to set foot here the site of
one of the worst nazi atrocities during
world war ii
in june 1944 nazi soldiers killed 642
civilians here hundreds of them children
only six villagers survived
today aurador is a ghost town the ruins
preserved as a memorial to the dead
it won't be the first time that joachim
gawk has confronted germany's painful
history
as president he's also paid tribute to
nazi victims in italy and the czech
republic
but at home
gauk's visit to france hasn't been a big
talking point instead a student film has
gone viral the fake ad shows a car
running over a young adolf hitler
for taste or just another way to deal
with germany's nazi past
i mean over a million views on that
video is it poor taste or is it just a
mature country recognizing what happened
in its ugly past henrietta
well i think it's a difficult question
but first when you watch the video it's
shocking so you see that um still
people in germany kind of um
deal very carefully with the past as
well so because if it wouldn't be
shocking so no one nobody would watch
the video so um you see that there is
enough um
um
it's it's important yeah is it good
video
i think um i think it's okay to do that
yes
i mean that's saying a lot julius what
do you say i thought the video was well
executed uh the narrative is there right
now galco's visiting france this sort of
historic moment is set and so you know
entering the social media sphere with a
video like that especially if it's well
produced and the uh you know message is
sort of on point uh makes sure that you
know it gets picked up by the media and
sort of spreads virally at the same time
i think the significance of the event
and the visit and when we look back at
history i think the pictures that we see
from you know
from from history are so grave that you
have to look at this uh you know with
respect and with humility elise what do
you think i would very much agree with
the two others i mean i'm not a much
better fan about this video at all
because it has a lot of violence in it
however it at least puts some light on
sort of the events which is coming up in
the galaxy but isn't it a good thing
that young people are you know talking
about what happened and
um can
they're using the language of social
media today to get a point across i mean
isn't that something we should be
celebrating
yes we should and but the question is do
we have to make a video where a child is
run over by a car and to point to get
out this message right i mean does it
have to be run over by a german car he's
run over by a german guy
there's all there's a lot of subtext
there there's a lot of subjects that's
true but i mean still it's a child in
the end right and
so i'm
not so much convinced if we really use
this sort of brutal message or this
brutal pictures to get the message isn't
the question being asked there and this
is something that maybe in german
society no one once wants to to say out
loud or to talk about is if you had had
the chance if you could go back in time
and you could run into a small adolf
hitler wouldn't you also have run over
him
it's a difficult question to ask because
right i mean because it's a small child
in the beginning if you would like go
back and say should these sort of
attacks against hitler later on should
they have been so successful if you knew
that was going to happen i mean that's
that's what this video is asking you to
pretend
well i don't think first of all i don't
think it's only about hitler right it's
a whole society who was sick at the
moment and to just focus on like this
one person who's at the lead which is
clearly very important but it's sort of
not enough it's a sick society we had in
that time and i think we have to like
look in past not only like focus on this
one person what do you say julius one
thing it's good to have the debate and i
think it's good that young people are
getting involved and sort of taking a
look at this and taking a stab at it
from the from a different perspective
but there's so much only so much you can
communicate in 30 second video but it's
a lot it's it's a lot and it sort of you
know it gets the debate going but i
think it has to be opened up and i think
it would be nice to sort of have more
information provided on top of the video
uh maybe create a campaign all around it
but um i think they've done a fantastic
job sort of raising the issue in the
public debate henrietta what about the
importance of eurodoor i mean it's not
getting a lot of play here in germany
what about for the french
um it's a bit different for for france
there's a lot of media coverage but
there's been in germany as well when
gauc announced that he would go there
and president gawk go there so um
there's media coverage in france because
it's um it's a very important um
like event or
memory in
in france actually so it's taught in
schools and
what is taught in school in germany
coming to terms with the past accepting
the identity of being the perpetrators
those are things that are hammered in to
students here do the french dedicate
the proper amount of time to the vichy
regime and the fact that they
collaborated with the nazis
well that changed over time as well so
like in the early years after the war
there were um
purchase um to to actually um find them
collaborationists and um they were
killed and they were also trialed and
then there was a time when nothing
happened actually and in the 90s with
shirak there was a lot of investigations
and
shirak also stated that um the french
state hasn't um played like has a
responsibility actually so there was a
lot of um um changes in the 90s and
right now as well but it's still ongoing
so it's um but
the the french they acknowledge the
atrocities and they they also see that
um they
some of them played and played a role in
having responsibility let me ask all of
you since all of you um at the table are
germans what should president gel
well it's hard to say i mean first would
you say should say like
his conlance and his big story to the
people out there and he says like admit
the guilt which is on the german people
um which the crimes they have done there
and to work uh further to sort of
um
keep these crimes in mind and sort of to
go from there
you agree julius i do but i think the
polyoptics are more important i think
it's sort of the pictures that we're
seeing uh the the gesture of german head
of state going over there uh reaching
out and sort of telling people this is
not going to be forgotten i think that's
the most most important message said
that's been said time and time well i
think you have to say it over and over
but at the same time i think the debate
that we're having here and i think that
debate that the viral video might be
sparking as well is that you know at the
same time while we can't forget
something like that and the atrocities
that have been committed some point we
have to move on we have to sort of you
know move beyond so to make sure that we
understand this is a generation that's
passed us you know there's you know not
we don't have any sort of
guilt anymore while the prosecution is
rolling up the case again and might
bring charges again i think it's
important that we as a society get to a
point is that true though is are you is
your generation are you a guilt-free
german generation
i think
while we remember uh what happened and
so we see the significance and we of
course commit to not forgetting i think
you know there's certainly uh something
that we can't be held responsible for
and i think at some point uh we have to
be able to say proudly and loudly that
we're germans and we should feel
feel compelled to say so so
anyway what do you say actually i think
it's um it's it's still important to
that these visits take place so i think
there's um there's never an end to that
and it's very important to frankly
german relationships as well because
these symbolic gestures as you said they
are so important for creating um these
relations the special relationship
between france and germany so you need
these pictures actually do you feel
guilty i mean are you a generation free
of guilt that's my question well
um i can't really tell you um just like
that if i feel guilty or not but it's
part of my history of part of our
history so
i'm kind of aware of it and you learn it
in school and you you know what happened
so it's um
briefly briefly the symbolism there are
still two survivors uh you know from
that instance you know shall we still be
sending the the perpetrators to prison
even if they're in their 90s
justice should be served okay we're
running out of time here but let me ask
all of you i mean since we've been
talking about the election and politics
so much after september 22nd who will be
the chancellor of germany steinbrook or
merkel sadly michael
close elections you got to go vote
give me an answer julius i think right
now the numbers looking in favor of
merkel okay henry i agree actually
probably miracle okay thank you very
much all three of you for being honest i
think we've got a politician on our
hands here that's gonna wrap up my
agenda this week keep the conversation
going chime in at facebook and twitter
you can tweet me at brentgoth tv i'm
always happy to see what you folks are
thinking and remember our inbox is
always open you see the address on your
screen right there don't forget you can
watch the show again on our website and
on youtube i'm brent kaufman berlin join
me next time when i set the agenda
you